hello everybody and welcome back to the
amnesia custom story abduction all right
we're about to go in the mine here ah
cooked no we're not huh thank you all of
God mess up your bottles whoa oh yeah we
don't like me now yeah all right what
the hell what the heck oh do I have a
key
oh of course I have to keep Dawg I'm
stupid for me all right
what other not scary things await me huh
like everything gimme oh thank you oil
thank you oil gods for providing me with
this bountiful oil feast mine is
terribly confusing man oh great
uh everything looks alike cinnabar vein
love me some cinnabar oh boy awk here
remember that left right left till or
extract or 80 degrees left left straight
right straight I my memory is good but I
can't do that
oh you don't even remember ha ha okay
I'm boned oh damn it Oh F me hard core
Oh F me
f me ah what the hell what the hell what
the hell what the hell ah get out of
here get are you what what what what
what what why noise why noise uh uh get
down here ah give me it's a rat it's a
rat
ah [ __ ] you I'm bleeding quite badly
uh oh I'm going the wrong way right left
right straight turn 180 find it or left
left straight right I don't know just
the or is this or I get out of here rat
where are you I don't see you what is or
what is this or okay 180 ah laughs OH
left left straight right okay left left
straight rights right ah left left
what is straight no right I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what's going on oh [ __ ] I've done ah no
no no no no rat
you get out of here I'm not afraid to
you I'm not afraid of you stop it stop
it seriously I don't like this uh oh
why where is it how's it doing this to
me how how what the [ __ ] seriously
ah fu man but you like punish me me for
going the wrong way then we're doing
what you do do to me oh man
I don't know oh I don't know anymore I
don't I don't know
oh come on Jesus I hear it I feel it nan
my bones and I can do nothing about it
it must just be triggered when I go to a
place I don't know yep there's another
one I'm using up all my log numb I don't
like this I'm so lost I'm so lost I'm
wasting oil so very lost I'll get out
here rat
I'll get out of here oh where am I going
what am i doing oh come on
Oh F me was this it did I just come in a
big circle please let this be the way
out and not something else stupid oh let
me know let me know
oh yes finally Oh God oh that was the
worst I used up like all of my laudanum
okay
oh no you got me I didn't get a damn
thing
ah oh I was supposed to get the hammer
and chipper Oh F me oh I'm so stupid
guys oh I'm not more idiot I'm a [ __ ]
idiot
fine I saw the rock I didn't do anything
about it
oh look at me F F in the a oh whatever
whatever okay I remember this left
[Music]
right got here right left and there's
the rock genius I'm just gonna go back
the way I came because F this man
alright leave this infested place you've
got it ah oh that oh that oh you blocked
the way back didn't you didn't you
didn't check yep f me me oh no yeah here
I'm never gonna be able to remember the
way back this is a maze a bad maze rats
in it oh I get it
rats in a maze I'm tired of these
[ __ ] rat
this [ __ ] cave oh I'm dead I'm
so dead only got one Laden to me left
god damn it I'm boned just I'm boned Bo
and 3d ah gah
oh gum [ __ ] rats [ __ ] the rats
seriously I'm gonna die but I'm gonna
die here my dying there's not damn thing
I can do about it
F these rats man seriously F them this
is stupid
this is stupid oh one more bite and I'm
Bonin I'm right at the eggs in our night
God get away seriously this is the most
annoying mechanic ever it's not fun just
plain annoying
ah get out of here rats I can't see you
if I can't do anything about the threat
that's just that's it that's it stupid
alright alright I'm better I'm okay
I guess they made it their stupid
mechanic so that it couldn't kill you
whatever though whatever get out of here
and now that everything's blood red
can't see a damn thing
oh this is fun I like this whoo-hoo-hoo
get me ah angry girl upset I am
Oh bring on a water monster I don't hit
on one mess with me right now but I get
grumpy I get super strong break up break
a mountain in half dig a tunnel Dacula
yeah
oh right Oh everything's Ruud Oh too
much blood dripping down my face okay
I'm guessing I take this rock and I put
it in the lever
squeezing oh I missed my exit the lever
squeezing heat majiggy where I've got my
jar of blood yep here we go okay thank
goodness this is still do pretty buddy
okay
and then ha ha just right am i doing
this okay uh-huh okay ah no no aah
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you no no I'm in a corner you can't see
me you can't see me you f off so hard f
you f you f you f you f you if you a foo
foo foo foo foo foo Fah go away go away
go oh wait I'm behind a barrel you can't
see me make the right choice man it's a
good choice okay ah okay oh man for the
first time in this custom story hiding
has worked properly oh yeah
get out of here buddy you are an a-hole
capital a H w5z hey hold on oh don't
mess with me will don't mess with me
again
God they they extracted the code from
penumbra and then made it stupider God
all right huh come on cook cook you oh I
need to add of course bromine there we
go
finally JW's potion I'm guessing this is
the portal potion huzzah
not from Aperture Science ha ha very
funny you a comedic genius
get me out of here get me out of here
out of here all right moving on
ok sewers no water monster juice nope
all right I have to pause it here thank
you guys so much for watching as always
I truly appreciate each and every one of
you and uh so I will see you guys in the
next part
bye-bye